um
what is the best part of of the
quarantine i know that there's a lot of
down parts but what is the part that you
feel like
you've appreciated the most about the
world kind of chilling for a little bit
you know it's unfortunate for all the
people who
lost their jobs and yeah of course my
grandma passed lost their homes
you know lost their lives lost
everything
and you know i i hate to turn you know i
i hate to like
i'm not really boasting about it but
i've definitely you know i go on with
the mind frame of positivity always so
i did kind of change my whole [ __ ]
around so it forced me to just chill
i have a brand new baby so i was able to
be with my child every single day
you know watch him grow every single day
get his first little teeth take his
first little step
make his first little noise you know
what i mean so
feed him nourish him take care of my
lady
spend time with her do nature situations
and really you know recharge and get a
grasp on ourselves and
and reflect kind of i mean you know it
was a forced reflection and i
i me i i definitely needed this because
if i didn't who knows what would have
happened maybe i would have died or
been in a [ __ ] hospital or some [ __ ]
who knows what the [ __ ]
yeah i think it was like a forced like
it kind of re forced everybody to get
their priorities together
yeah you know what i'm saying well not
everybody you [ __ ] a lot of people's
minds up and they went the other way but
you know
only the strong survive and you know
hopefully
hopefully people will be able to you
know to overcome